[Music]
today is small business saturday a day
when consumers are encouraged to do our
holiday shopping at small locally owned
stores and businesses and in a shopping
season when so many items are stuck out
at sea you can still find holiday gifts
that were manufactured right here at
home
the buzz of making in mills and
factories around the country may make
the season bright
we ship them usually within 24 hours
that's 24 hours after an order comes
into janet wishnia's american blossom
linen mill in georgia everything is done
here in the united states we have people
that spin the yard weave the fabric
manufacture the boxes want a massage
chair made from texas call tom lee at la
rocco people have a hard time getting
the product from overseas we have a full
inventory how about organic cotton
zikano socks gina locklear makes in
alabama our october sales are up around
80 percent so far this year so
something is going on
we're not quite sure what finding u.s
made products has been made easier by
usalovelist.com
a website sarah wagner created and runs
from an unlikely place so this is it the
office is the laundry room this is my
office
it's cozy with others helping from their
homes more than 5 000 u.s made brands
are listed by state mr ice bucket ice
buckets okay tandoor chef frozen foods
now those are things i would never even
think to look for and well and there's
plenty more baby toys
outdoor toys
how about that
look at that
mississippi what's posted meets the
federal trade commission's usa-made
requirements all significant parts and
processing that go into the product
must be of u.s origin
right in tracking visits to her website
sarah wagner saw a 500 percent spike
when much of the country shut down since
october it's up 25 percent but so what
can't people get
a toaster is a big one that everybody it
drives them crazy they really want an
american-made toaster they can't get
small electronic items what would need
to change for those pieces to be
manufactured here again entirely new
manufacturing facilities would need to
be built but in an old georgia mill
facing bankruptcy janet wisnia and her
husband have reimagined the linen
business she inherited our company was
started in 1931 by my grandfather
in philadelphia in georgia the thomaston
mill they saved makes american blossom
linens a new brand threaded with cotton
grown without pesticides one of the big
things is made out of western west texas
organic cotton and they ship in usa made
boxes that are well they are recycled
tom lee's recliner chairs include
lessons learned as a military contractor
we have several projects for u.s army
and u.s air force the engineering he and
his brother studied after immigrating
from vietnam drives the company along
with what happened when the war ended he
put my dad
seven years in the they called
reeducation camp
but after a thank you to the u.s
government
they sponsor our family to the u.s 42
patents later american dream the organic
socks gina locklear designs and makes
come from fort payne alabama which is
formerly known as the stock capital of
the world half the country's socks were
once made there so when the mills closed
i personally had friends who were
affected by it because their parents had
lost their jobs a modest museum downtown
commemorates 100 mills that shut down
her family's was one of the few hanging
on when she finished college one reason
why i started this was because i wanted
to talk about
our family story about why it's so
important to support things that are
made here in our country love list.com
started with a journey too
in 2011 in a winnebago on a family road
trip i started to notice that some of
these small towns were
delightful places other small towns had
seen better days
and i realized that the difference
between those towns was whether they
were making something that's when our
treasure hunt began i started it as a
twitter account to just to
see what kind of level of interest there
was just to see if people still cared
about american made yeah and they did it
there was instant
interest and that grew into the site the
links to the products go along with some
advice too what would you tell folks out
there in the market for this gift giving
season i would encourage shoppers to
remember the businesses that were there
for them
during these last couple of difficult
years it's really up to the consumer
every single one product that i buy
makes a difference to a business
and makes a difference to a worker whose
job
is part of that business
and this trend of
u.s companies sending jobs overseas
began in 1980 we lost 7.5
million u.s manufacturing jobs in the
last 30 years it is just incredible to
see the possibility the possibility of
it coming back great ingenuity sign me
up for socks from fort payne
sock capital of the world